okay that face was horrible yeah yeah I
came there I will never make that face
again I think they would have just kept
clapping I think you know what I think
we I think we could have killed the rest
of the show with me making face please
what kind of show is that yeah a show
where we don't have to do nothing
welcome to Pavlov's dogs Arnie here's
how the survey works we asked three
celebrities to complete a phrase our
first phrase was I know I've done
something wrong when Matthew Perry said
my conscience won't leave me alone
Reese Witherspoon said I get a funny
feeling in the pit of my stomach
Bill O'Reilly said I'm given a check for
25 million dollars I got my current job
through a combination of Elizabeth
Warren said hard work and perseverance
drew Brees said preparation and
precision Ivanka Trump said sperm and
egg
president Trump's latest comment about
the Civil War made me feel Maxine Waters
said outraged Don Lemon said alarmed
George W Bush said smart at 3:00 a.m. at
3:00 a.m. a president should not be
tweeting he should be President Obama
said sleeping President Bush said
sleeping President Clinton said texting
his wife that the car broke down again
and then he'll be home soon nothing
fishy going on holding on never right
nothing fishy going on a bad idea out of
bed dick my favorite thing to do at the
beach is Zac Efron said boogie board
Lisa Kudrow said relax and catch some
Ray's Mitch McConnell said crawling onto
the shore and laying my egg
whenever whenever I have dinner with a
woman who's not my wife I Tom Hanks said
have a perfectly normal evening Matthew
Broderick said enjoy a perfectly normal
conversation Mike Pence said seriously
masturbate under the table he's been
thrown out of so many Apple B I know
[Applause]
these are all real I hope it's healthy
too Jennifer Aniston said drink red wine
Jack Black said eat red meat
Steve Annan said poop a mixture of
hardened clay and old taco wrappers
it is when I don't want people to
recognize me I eva longoria said wear a
hat in sunglasses
Tom Selleck said shave my mustache Sean
Spicer said tell the truth and finally I
remember my dad saying Terry Crews said
put yourself in someone else's shoes Ted
Danson said early to bed and early to
rise Larry King said let there be light
oh we love you Larry
you